[Music]
not long ago scenes like this were
common nine out of every 10 Brazilian
children receiving their regular
vaccines it took three decades of hard
work to build a public health system in
Brazil reaching the most remote areas of
Latin America's largest country but
medical professionals say the
vaccination program has been all but
destroyed in just the last four years
the worst blow inflicted by President
John bolsonaro's right-wing government
was to our credibility we spent 30 years
convincing Brazilians to get their free
shots regularly but bolsonaro's caused
so many doubts about the efficacy that
now only 60 percent of our children are
being vaccinated as a result diseases
like measles and polio which had been
eradicated on making a comeback
revitalizing Brazil's public health
system is but one of many challenges
president-elect luisi National will have
to face once he takes office on January
1st
education is another the covid-19
pandemic coupled with a lack of
investment has increased the education
gap between rich and poor and between
whites and blacks
bolsonaro wanted to end the affirmative
action policies establishing racial
quotas and universities he couldn't but
stopped giving students financial aid
for transportation and accommodation as
a result 30 percent of those who
benefited from quotas had to drop out
because they had no money to travel back
and forth for the pandemic that went up
to 50 percent
the virus also closed Public Schools
nine-year-old vinicius like many who
live in Rios favelas forgot much of what
he had learned
I was unemployed I just had another baby
and had no money for Wi-Fi or food for
vinicius studying on his own on an empty
stomach was almost impossible
and that is perhaps Lola's greatest
challenge her being hunger
Brazil is one of the world's largest
exporters of grain and meat but
volunteers here are scrambling for
donations to feed a small portion of the
country's growing number of hungry the
NGO citizenship action has collected 1
500 tons of food this is enough to feed
600
000 Brazilians but it's a drop in the
bucket compared to the 33 million that
have nothing to eat that is the same
number of hungry people Brazil had 30
years ago a number reduced to four and a
half million by 2014. now the country is
back to square one
citizenship action blames successive
right-wing governments for reducing by
96 percent investments in Social plans
to reduce poverty from 2016 2022 that
hungered Rose from 4.5 million people to
33 million people that's 15 percent of
the country living in complete hunger
Lula has promised to continue
Distributing 120 dollar monthly
emergency handouts to the poor as
bolsonaro did during the pandemic he
also promised an additional thirty
dollars for every needy child but
finding the money to solve so many
pressing social demands at a time when
the economy is in crisis will be perhaps
Lula's biggest challenge overall Monica
yanaki of Al Jazeera Rio de Janeiro